hi friends we are back again and this
week we're talking about life hacks but
perhaps with a little bit of a different
angle
Carles cederstrom is an associate
professor at Stockholm Business School
part of Stockholm University and his
writing has appeared in the New York
Times The Guardian The Atlantic and
Harvard Business Review amongst many
others Karl spent 12 months immersed in
the human optimization movement him and
his co-author Andre Spicer dedicated one
month of the year to a different area of
their life and trying to optimize it as
much as possible this is the absolute
zenith Mount Everest of trying to
optimize your life and the experiences
that car went through ever listed some
really really interesting results he'll
tell us exactly what out of 12 months of
pure optimization was the single best
tool that he came across how he was able
to optimize his sex his relationships
his vanity his looks his finances and a
whole bunch of other things and then we
move on to his new book which is called
the happiness fantasy now recently we've
discussed happiness quite a bit with
Susana Hallinan and in the Q&A that I
did with Johnny and Yusuf and it's an
interesting to see cars approach to it
and he makes a strong case that
happiness isn't something that any of us
should be aiming for and that there are
much more worthy terms that would make
us much more fulfilled and content
within life I'm gonna leave it there
I won't present any spoilers for the
rest of the episode but I want you to
give another shout out to Scott McGrath
who sent in a screenshot of him sending
out on another company internal intranet
one of our podcast episodes now thanks
very much for that Scott I really
appreciate it again if you do manage to
share one of the episodes on a big
network please let me know and I'll be
able to give you a shout out on a future
episode coming up soon we have got how
to survive University me John Yin Yusuf
talking about that and the long awaited
life
fales 101 edition which is essentially
the antithesis to a very slick approach
to human optimization so there's lots of
exciting stuff coming up but for now his
car
[Music]
mr. Kyle cederstrom how are you today
I'm very good thank you how are you
doing very good thank you all the way
from the increasingly cold England at
the moment where are you in the world
I'm in the increasingly cold Sweden
Stockholm to be precise very nice your
associate professor at Stockholm
Business School right that's right which
is part of Stockholm University
fantastic for the listeners at home
could you give us a little bit of a
background to yourself please
all right well I live in Sweden been
living in the UK in Cardiff for a few
years but now based here live in
Stockholm two children a wife and the
author of a few books which are believed
we will talk a little bit about what
else can I tell you that's it's really I
think that that would be necessary to
know that's that reform of the zeitgeist
tape - Karl cederstrom I like you did
you did you manage to tune your hearing
into the Welsh accent very quickly when
you were over there
well I mean I could I could still now -
don't spot it and recognize it quite
excellent much more easily than before
but I was never able to imitate it
anything like the world's accent it's
very it's very subtle I mean I I'm you
know my English is just too inferior to
imitate any kind of accent just a
Swedish maybe maybe I could do a French
German or Danish accent if I really fire
- I got here what I want I won't make
you jump through that hurdle today
Thanks that's okay
um so I want to get straight into it um
you have had an interesting journey with
the field of human optimisation would
that be fair to say mmm-hmm yeah that's
fair to say a lot of the listeners will
know we have our most popular series is
a sequence of episodes called life hacks
and on those we try and find tips and
tricks
jeez and approaches for a productive and
efficient life and you took the human
optimization movement to an extreme for
12 months yourself and your co-author
and friend Andre Spicer is that right
that's right I mean the background to
that project is that both me and Andre
two university professors who spent just
too much time in our life in front of a
computer sitting on a chair in our
offices and studying various things and
we both been interested for a long time
in the optimization movement and we'd be
interested in in self held culture and
we wrote a book a number of years ago
called a wellness syndrome which was
really a critical diagnosis of would be
called a wellness society a society
where everyone is really so commanded
where there is an injunction to be well
to be happy to be healthy unless you you
know live up to those requirements you
seen as a worse person so I mean this is
really what it all began with many years
ago and you were interested in
understanding this culture from a more
sociological political and philosophical
perspective and then when that book came
out in 2015 a number of people said but
look guys did you really try any of
these things and the truth was that we
had rarely left our offices for the last
I don't know 10 or 20 years so I never
tried you know never been to a tomb I've
never tried mindfulness I really I I
tried nothing really so we thought why
not write a book where we start on
January 1st and spend an entire year and
try all of those things that we've
written about from more theoretical
perspective a very slow distance
approached and just immerse ourself into
this culture and do everything that a
human being could possibly do to
optimize every area of our lives so we
sat down together over lunch when I was
visiting Andre in London where he lives
and we thought out 12 through
mein broad categories of optimization
areas various things that you could
optimize in your life and so we just
wrote down these twelve categories
starting in January with productivity in
February and optimizing the body March
was optimizing the brain then relations
and spirituality then sex enjoyment
money creativity morality vanity and
then finally trying to work out what is
a deeper or through wider implications
of this project was so that was the kind
of optimization project which took place
in 2016 starting in January and ending
by the end of December what was that
like living that year well I think I
think now it's it's it's like you're in
your forties and look look back to your
20s and thinking that that was probably
fun but there's no way I would ever do
it again but it was I mean there were
some things which which were quite quite
interesting I think on a more sort of
fundamental level what it means to start
playing with your life and start
experimenting with various aspects of
your life which really allows you to do
things which you would normally not do
and I think also for us doing this thing
together really help because we pushed
ourselves to do things we we would never
have dreamt of doing otherwise and it
was also something strangely comforting
waking up every morning and knowing
exactly what it was that you were
supposed to do and some people said that
one month was a very it's a very short
period of time and there's no way you
could optimize an air in one month time
which is true but also you realize when
you do that how long a month is yeah and
I think you know in during many of these
months it felt as though they would
never never end so of all of the areas
that you moved through which one was the
most trying or which one did you find to
be the either most difficult or most
uncomfortable
yes sex definitely and and I'm pretty
sure Andre would have said sex as well
though that was really the most
difficult one and also since we're both
married we had to we had to try and find
alternative routes to go down me was to
try and optimize masturbation which you
know sounds absolutely outrageous but of
course it turns out that there's a whole
body of literature and gurus and you
know professional wankers who would tell
you I've worked with some professional
wankers in my time actually yeah and you
know fascinating when you begin
listening to them because they would
really see life as being a sort of pre
and post you know learning to become a
sort of sexual kung-fu master which
means that you could you know master
multiple orgasms and you know reject and
I met a physical level almost the
ejaculation and instead embrace orgasm
Estus very powerful energy that was
opposed to greater than a physical the
physical manifestations itself I want to
ask your question that I'm sure a lot of
girlfriends and wives at home are
thinking which is what did your
girlfriends or wives what did they think
about the year that you were doing would
they just sort of turning over in bed at
night and hoping that you weren't gonna
wake them up to something else mental in
the morning or what what was the
sentiment yeah I mean I think I think my
wife wouldn't anything was really tired
of over and over again and I think I
think the most the most testing bit
really was people around asking you know
how do you feel about this what I tried
to do was to you know when you put
yourself through and you here a
year-long experiment of this kind you
need to be very careful about the things
you're ready to sacrifice and the things
you don't want to sacrifice and I think
in my case the family was was very
important so I tried to
keep the project and experiments
whenever possible within you know
working or office hours okay keep the
family life insulated so to speak from
the from the experiment I try to of
course yeah so we've talked about one of
the the lower points of the journey what
was some of the the real highlights that
you took from it can you tell us can you
tell us anything that you thought was
really really good that you went through
yeah yeah I mean a lot of it I mean okay
so I mean one of the things that really
worked was maximizing productivity so
the book that you were supposed to
interview me about the the happiness
fantasy it's her book said that that was
the book that I had to write in one
month's time so this was the first the
first test was to see if we could if we
could finish an academic book in in the
period of one month from scratch well I
had when starting I had about I think
one chapter finished and had to finish
five chapters so I think pretty much
what say 80% of the book I had I had to
write plus then because I can go back
through it all again and yeah I mean I
did send it off to the publisher which I
had which was under contract and you
know this is just going to ruin the
whole story now that they rejected the
manuscript but and then I was just and
an interesting thing you saw okay so
this is what happens I wake up January 1
and I know that in 31 days I need to
write this freaking book and he doesn't
really know no time to lose and so what
I do is I meet are sort of productivity
coach and he gives me a series of really
helpful advice I think the advice I
would really recommend to everyone
especially if they work with writing or
many other sort of creative tasks is
the Pomodoro Technique which may sound
very you know simple almost you know
silly but it's it's really fantastic and
and I would say if this if there's one
thing that really came out of this year
which I still use on a daily basis it is
the Pomodoro Technique which very simply
means that you sit down and work in a
very concentrated fashion for 25 minutes
and then there's a small beak from your
app or whatever or if you use just an
egg clock and as for our egg timer and
then you take a five minute break and
the rule which i think is very important
to follow is that when you take the
break you should do nothing ideally just
stare out the window or on a boiling
kettle and as soon as the five minute
break is over you sit down again and
this may sound really counterintuitive
let's say you're in the middle of a
sentence
you know crafting a centers and things
are going really really well and then
the beat goes of course you know you
would think that I should sit here and
and you know let this little creative
flow continue but I think if you just
stand up take the break and then after
five minutes go back again you know
exactly where to start and then you can
recuperate enough so you could keep
going and it's interesting if you do
this over the course of a day because I
think the first five or six Pomodoro's
you think that okay I don't really need
to take a break now but it really gives
you the stamina to carry on working for
a much longer period of time and still
in a concentrated fashion so that and
also the addition of some medications
which I was experimenting with which
worked really well but that was really
the the key to getting the e-book the
book done even though it's fairly short
and it was rejected by the first
publisher oh yeah and but the the
finished project product one absence yes
as I did work it over last awesome
anyway but so yeah I think if I had to
single out one thing
really worked over the course of that
year I'd say productivity well that's
the Pomodoro Technique is a common theme
i'ma stood a listeners at home that were
not sponsored by the Pomodoro Technique
the this seems to be it definitely seems
to be a tool of choice for writers and
creative types doctor you and Lawson who
I did a podcast with that was a lot to
do with the ergonomics of your desk
environment your general working
environment he said that he could go
back through 150 Pomodoro's that he did
and he could track absolutely everything
he'd done during his contribution to the
book that he wrote which he calmed and
he could go back through and he actually
came up with it's interesting that you
you touched on looking out of the window
because he came up with a rule called
the 20-20-20 rule which I guess with the
Pomodoro we did 25 20 20 but when he
talks about is re focusing the eyes on
an object which is 20 feet away for 20
seconds every 20 minutes and one of the
reasons for this is to reset the oculus
muscles within the mood within the eye
to reduce eye strain reduce tension
headaches and a few other bits and
pieces but I since that and over the
last six months have tried to implement
the Pomodoro Technique as much as I can
and for anyone who is listening they
will know that we are a massive fan of
the Pomodoro Technique for productivity
I think timeboxing anything that
Parkinson's law is just it's like one of
its like gravity right I think for a lot
of people it's just something that you
cannot get around work expands to fill
the time given for it and when you give
yourself that countdown clock in the
corner of the screen or the little
turning away egg timer or whatever it is
it just reminds you it usually reminds
you how much [ __ ] time you're wasting
yeah I mean definitely I mean it was
really remarkable because I was for
every chapter I was writing I was just
you know in the app you could choose
what activity you're going to spend that
Pomodoro on so I I could see when the
book was
time that I had spent almost exactly the
same amount of Pomodoro's on each
chapter which is really quite strange
when you think about it but it means
there really is some kind of like I
think sort of intuitive process that
really works if you just make sure to
sit in front of the computer and don't
actually actually do your [ __ ] work
that's right
so getting onto the larger topic of
optimization overall at the moment have
you have you managed to come to a
conclusion about why there is a
modern-day obsession with optimization
yeah I mean I think by the end of this
the desperately seeking book I I kind of
I was left with three three theories and
and the first one is that there is a
deeply there's a deep human desire to be
someone else or somewhere else basically
just to escape the confines of of who
you are and I think everyone is born
with you know multiple dreams of what
you could become and I think that's just
something something deeply human so of
course optimization or self help for
that matter at promises and that is
really powerful is that you could live a
different life I mean your life could be
different from how it looks now so I
think that's a very very strong deeply
human impulse and then the second theory
is that really now we we live in a time
where were expected to do these things I
mean I think we do live in a culture
which is very individualized and we are
being trained at an early age in school
and elsewhere to begin think of
ourselves in terms of what we can do in
relationship to these sort of the market
economy I mean what are we going to do
when we grow up how it
going to make money and not only in
terms of what are you going to become in
terms of your your trade your occupation
but you know what are the kind of
creative and innovative ways that you
could think about remaking yourself as
valuable commodities so I think there's
a kind of commodification of of life and
and we're really - that's a really good
way to put it it come on if a commodity
vacation of life yeah you're totally
right yeah and we're really so
indoctrinated to think thinking about
what can produce value and where there's
really no distinction between the work
that we do in the person that we are and
it's not only working on other things
but working on ourselves I think the
whole little optimization culture is
very strongly linked to that kind of
competitive element of modern-day
capitalism so that's the second theory
and then the third theory is also very
so classic one which I think he's
escaped from death really and I mean I
don't say that
in a sort of face easiest way or that
there's something wrong with escaping
death I think we're all trying to escape
nobody wants to know in ways nobody
wants to die and but there are different
ways obviously it's escaped death but I
mean if you take one of the more radical
things I did during the optimization the
year of optimization it was to have
plastic surgery so this was a month
where I was going to spend every day and
all the money I had try and become as
beautiful as as possible so I went to
one of these clinics where you get
injections you know it's called
Restylane these sort of filler
injections okay so I was going to get a
sort of broader and sort of sharper what
your line a jawline that's right
a sharper jawline and and you know when
when I come in there there's this woman
in a white robe and she looks at me and
I'd tell her I want to be as beautiful
as as possible and you know she looks at
me and you know for her that's a
perfectly normal question
she moves me over to the mirror and I
look in the mirror so well you have a
slightly boyish look so maybe we could
try and make you look a little bit more
like a George Clooney and I've been
thinking more something like Cristiano
Ronaldo or Justin Bieber I thought
George Clooney sounds great so I went
for the for the big picture or like a
full George Clooney maker for default
clean a makeover but but I mean if you
go into a clinic like that and those are
this this woman who I met it was
absolutely impossible to say how old she
was because you couldn't see a wrinkle
anywhere in her face or any other people
I met in in that clinic and and
obviously that's a way of escaping death
I mean you could you could see how
different forms of exercise I was going
to CrossFit gym membership which lasted
until just a few months ago it was
getting too expensive but that is also a
place where you meet 4050 sometimes
6-year old people who really believe
that they are going to be younger I mean
they take all of these different fitness
tests which will tell them that you know
from a bodily perspective physical
perspective there are only 20 or 25 I
think again that is a way of trying to
escape death and so I think all of these
different activities of optimization I
think even when it comes to in part
optimizing productivity you really want
to be able to do do all of these things
in life before life is over so as I can
that's that's a form of of escaping
death again so I mean I'd say those four
this was three so broad Mother's I could
could think of and then my friend
Honduras would we had a discussion about
this by the end of the year he thought
it was also about escaping especially
you know if you're a middle-aged person
as we are with with families so for him
it was also a way of escaping the family
was a way of escape being yourself as
well I'm having that normality of human
life almost
that's right the normality of human life
and also the the distress and the
anxiety that a lot of people feel in
those you know everyday life situations
so you've touched on something I promise
to the listeners at home that we haven't
shared notes before we did this but
you've touched on something I really
wanted to get to do you think the
optimization is people searching for
meaning in life through progression
they're overcoming an obstacle and
chasing down a task is a good way of
artificially inseminating a feeling of
meaning in your life because when you
reach the goal it's the same as I want
to get the bigger house I want to have
the bigger car I want to do x y&z I
training CrossFit gyms all the time and
a lot of the people that are there they
want that 200 kilo deadlift they want
that 102 at 20 kilo clean-and-jerk and
you're like okay well when you get there
all that you're doing is moving the
you're moving your PB up by 5 kilos and
going for it again there's a there's got
to be a broader question about what
makes life worth living
and is it these little the little
intermediary targets or are people using
that as an escapism mechanism to to
forget the fact that the overarching
that life a lot of the time for a lot of
people is suffering what what's your
what you take on that that's that's a
great question I think I mean we I think
we need to put this in perspective over
how we are being brought up today in in
school and especially when it comes to
the point you know when you're in your
early twenties and you need to start
thinking about what you should do with
your life and we really brought up you
know through commercials and through I
kind of business-type thinking that we
need to progress in some ways our lives
should be like that some toothpaste
commercial when you see how wonderfully
rich and healthy your teeth become off
using a toothpaste or your hair become
after using a shampoo and again when it
comes to work and reading any kind of
you know business-related literature I'm
from a beast
school which is also part of why I'm
interested in this but how we really
being taught and trade train into
thinking that everything needs to
progress but then we find ourselves in a
situation today where people who either
are looking for jobs and do everything
they can to sell whatever resources they
have there's some human resources on the
market that is usually quite cold and
you don't really know what to do in
order to that progress and to make it
and also for people who do have work
they may be working in marketing or
sales and they may be working their ass
off and still by the end of the day
they're not really sure where their
effort really paid off or not yeah but
then when it comes to the gym now you
step into a CrossFit gym and you're
there and you struggle and you fight and
you sweat and you're really put in all
of the hard labor and it pays off I
think is really one of the few areas in
life today where you can see progress
you've gotten much more you've got much
more direct line of causation between
your efforts put in and the results that
come out the other end
totally right Natalie you need to
navigate the office politics you need to
grease the right shoulders and there's a
lot more hurdles to get over I think for
some people that's why CrossFit is
incredibly liberating because people who
maybe aren't at the top of their game in
terms of societal values for what their
particular job is can go in and if
they've been working their ass off and
you as a successful businessman have
been being lazy they're gonna wipe the
floor with you in the workout today and
it evens it evens the playing field in
an incredibly fair way yeah but I think
one of the things that you touched on
was really really interesting was about
this that the fact that someone's
progression and they're they're almost
inseparable from their job right I mean
what's one of the first things when you
meet somebody hi what's your name what
do you do you know you you are your job
that's right you are your
and then at the same time you we also
know that most people find their jobs
essentially meaningless so you have
David Graeber who came out with a book
[ __ ] jobs and this was based on an
essay he wrote a few years ago so our
[ __ ] job is a job that is not only
meaningless for you but you considered
the job to be meaningless on a more
fundamental social political level in
other words no use at all if that job
would not exist the world would either
be better off for good at least the same
right and they followed up after this
essay they made a survey a Yugo survey
which showed that something like 37
percent of UK workers find their jobs to
be [ __ ] and I think this is hugely
relevant when understanding the
commitment and the addiction that a lot
of people have to Jim culture that we
were supposed to find meaning and again
at progression and we're supposed to be
able to display that progression and
show people that we are progress and
we're supposed to do that in our working
life but it's just really really
difficult for most people to be able to
do that I mean if you do find yourself
in a bull you know so-called [ __ ]
job how are you going to be able to do
that and I think this is a this is a
great frustration for for a lot of
people and really so that tells tells us
a lot about how you know our culture is
is shaped today where work is so
essential I mean the only way to really
be able to convincingly tell someone
else that you have a meaningful life is
to say that you do this meaningful work
well that you are your work in some
respiratory correct there I think what's
what's really insidious about it is that
someone's position within a hierarchical
structure or how their job is regarded
by society at large
becomes conflated with their value to
society that I know an awful lot of
people and I'm sure that you do as well
who are commercially incredibly
successful I don't think that they add
an awful lot to society I don't think
they have a massive amount of value to
add however I've also got some friends
who are struggling students or singers
who can't make it haven't made a break
yet but that adds so much value to my
life I think they're fantastic fantastic
members of society and their value in in
quotation marks is in my eyes
significantly higher and it's this
conflation of value of job status with
value in society that seems it seems we
should treat that with a lot of
trepidation I think mmm-hmm yeah I agree
I think one of the other things it's
interesting to kind of bookend the
optimization bit coming out from the
other angle you're a professor of
business and in business the way that
the way that companies have become
better or more effective over the years
is that you try and approach you look at
what works remodel that you refine it
and then rinse and repeat over time that
it's split testing right it's a way of
the commercial world essentially
emulating what happens in the
evolutionary world and to one degree
there must be more effective ways and
less effective ways to operate within
the world there must be good ways to
exist as a human and there must be bad
ways or there must be better ways in
worse ways are probably a more effective
way of saying it so is this optimization
movement a bit of a bastardization of
that somehow is it where that's kind of
become twisted well so one thing that
really came out of the of the
optimization project is that there are I
think clear limits of what can be
optimized and what what areas allow
themselves to become optimized so
obviously when it comes to say
productivity or making money or anything
that would be over more kind of
practical instrumental nature you could
optimize
but as soon as it comes to racing you
know deeper philosophical question of
what it means to be a human being what
does it mean to be a ethical human being
what does it mean to connect in a loving
way with with other human beings then
all of a sudden you see the algorithms
the apps all of these difference of
operating systems to crash down the only
red berry they would have very very
little to offer us so I mean I think as
much as we could find useful advice to
help us through the day I think the
danger I mean the great danger of
optimization culture is that we begin
losing sight of those deeper questions
of what it means to be human and what it
is that we want to do with our lives
because obviously and this is kind of
how you phrased your question previously
is that as soon as you reach this target
or save up a bit of time by having
implemented a new technique then you
used time that you've saved up to find
more ways to save up more time and then
all of a sudden you have no freaking
clue what to do with that time and so I
think that's that that really is a great
danger of applying these mechanisms to
all areas of life now I deeply believe
there are things and very important
things I would say the most essential
things in life are really so outside the
scope outside you reach of optimization
that's interesting
so you've touched on something that I
want you two to talk about as we move
into the the discussion on your new book
to do with happiness hmm is halfway
between the two is the optimization
movement is it to do with individual
sovereignty versus more of a collective
kind of altruistic community society
approached desire to move everyone
forward together
is it the isolation a byproduct of the
21st century and capitalism do you think
sorry you meant the optimisation
movement would be one of these two
alternatives or the the optimization
movement are people obsessing over the
optimization movement because they no
longer have that sense of community
anymore okay yeah I guess you sorry and
yeah I mean I think I think clearly I
mean this is what a lot of sociologists
would would say and and usually you were
datas back to through the 1970s and you
have you know some some key reference
points like Christopher large writing in
the culture of narcissism you have feel
a brief a little bit earlier than that
speaking in the triumph of the
therapeutic that really today we had
lost faith in these various institutions
that used to give us meaning in life and
those institutions would be the family
would be Church typically would be work
all of these different social
institutions that shapes and gave a
sense of meaning to our lives just
crushed down and instead we are supposed
to find out by ourselves what a meaning
in life is and you really see how this
sort of the movement of the 1960's which
really had more of a kind of collective
and political flavor to it turn into
something different in the nineteen
seventies now these are very sort of
generalized remarks that I do here but
they would be be true at least when
we're looking at this with development
of of the self health movement and in
particular the many kind of these huge
seminar trainings that popped up and
became very popular in the 1970s we're
really the new emphasis was on the self
and the authentic self and the best one
could do is to look inside and to forget
about at the world and in justices that
may exist elsewhere because now when
you're here with yourself it's only the
cosmic universe and yourself that that
matters I just was the current of stuff
that was being trained at a very famous
seminar that I write about in the book
called s called Erhard seminars raining
where I can remember now is something
like 700,000 people I believe only went
between 1971 and 1984 and really is the
the message that people would receive
during these very intensive week weekend
long trainings is that there are no
victims in the world that was a very
very crucial point and that nothing in
your life is decided everything could be
changed and there would be no excuses
for anything so this was like a new kind
of it was a new version that sort of
became a sort of global or at least a
national in the u.s. phenomenon this dis
of course spread to many other countries
as well but which had the kind of the
same message that you find in the
self-help books of the 1930s you know
norman vincent peale how to win friends
and influence people yeah
thinking Grow Rich by Napoleon Hill
which also interests but but the kind of
interesting parallel fares that they
came out at the back of the Great
Depression and this was a time when
people really had to believe that there
was some kind of hope you know in the
face of a very so dark and depressing
feeling of hopelessness but
interestingly in the 1970s and this is
after time of you know three decades of
economic growth you have a new
generation or relatively wealthy middle
class people and there's a wonderful
essay written by Tom Wolfe that came out
in nineteen seventy six that said that
what all of these people did when they
finally get a little bit of money was to
take them and run and went off to places
like the Esalen Institute and asked to
have what he called a lube job
Miller Sol Sol Basin so and everything
the only thing that really mattered was
me myself and I and I kind of lifting up
inhaling the selfishness and being
egocentric was all of a sudden are
advertised yeah isn't it weird the odd
Li a byproduct of liberation has become
isolation yes yes there seems here one
of the things that you've come across
there is that individual agency and
freedom to make your own decisions and
this limitless bottomless side las'
topless world that you can create for
yourself makes you the master of your
own fate but it also means that all of
your failures and successes are entirely
yours to bear and as we all know the
look and environment play a huge part in
everything that goes on if you were born
in Rwanda in a terrible period during
the nineties when there's a massacre
going on but that's not your fault like
you're not the master of your own fate
there you haven't died murdered by
bandits on the back of Jeeps because you
weren't sufficiently well-educated or
something you're doing it because that's
what the situation that this situation
occurred is what was going on so I guess
there that leads us very nicely into the
next topic which is to do with happiness
so is is it a crisis of a lack of
meaning that's leading to happiness
being a almost replaced with progression
and and optimization at the moment could
you could you see a time a paradigm or a
spectrum so to speak between the two
books well I mean first of all I don't
believe in happiness I mean in the sense
that is there is a true definition of
happiness so that you could could
measure happiness in any clear or
scientific way and if you look at it
historically there's a really rich and
strange conceptual development and you
could see how he's you know if you look
down
yester you could see our happiness have
meant all different kinds of things in
different eras how so well I mean if you
take the in ancient Greece for example
and if you take the way Aristotle
understood happiness
it was very strongly connected to
developing a set of virtues it could be
to become more courageous and become
brave or you know to become a better
human being but very fundamental to the
belief of happiness at a time was that
true and complete happiness could only
be enjoyed by the gods not by human
beings the best that human beings could
do would be to strive for happiness but
never to attain happiness and that
notion of happiness remains for a very
very long time I mean if it remains
during the Middle Ages at which point
happiness did not really exist at all in
the life on earth but only in the
afterlife in heaven so true and complete
happiness was again something that was
beyond what a human could could achieve
and in the Renaissance that was the
first time that happiness started to
become seen as something that humans
could not fully grasp but something that
they could glimpse that and then it's in
the Enlightenment and with interestingly
philosophers like Mikey desaad but also
Rousseau and others where happiness
becomes not only something that you
could achieve but something that you
should achieve so now all of a sudden
happiness is something that is you know
something that that we need to achieve
and interesting the first thing that
happens is that that itself creates a
lot of trouble and has heard of misery
because when happiness is supposed to be
there supposed to be something that you
could hold on to and live then people
start
to feel miserable because they could not
achieve this they say that true agony is
the person you are meeting the person
you could have been right that's that's
that's the worst kind of hell and then
rolling back to our last point when we
were going through optimization this
Allah this individual agency making you
the master of your own fate what does
that mean that means you are no happy
therefore you are unhappy and in your
[ __ ] fault yeah if you carry on its I
mean even into the 20th century I mean
the dominant understanding of happiness
is that this is something that man and
this is what Freud said man the human
being is not particularly well designed
to achieve or or be able to handle
happiness we're really good at
unhappiness unhappiness comes from
everywhere it comes from our body
country matters surrounding come from
everywhere
happiness on the other hand is very
fleeting it's very difficult to know
where it comes from when it comes you
know you can't really hold on to it so
much the human being in happiness were
never really a couple made for each
other do you do that and I think I think
I do I do agree
I mean I'm not I'm not always in bed
with Freud but I think when it comes to
it I wouldn't ever want to be in bed
with Freud he had some very odd ideas
about what happens in bed yeah shopping
in bed with him but what's interesting
is that in the 1920s and this is one
what I write about in the Aventine the
happiness book the happiness fantasy
that this is other psychoanalyst he's
really young at the time called will
Henrik and he makes a great impression
on Freud for the leaves
you know his is great but there's a very
strong disagreement between the two
which becomes very obvious after a while
and that is how they see the
relationship between happiness and the
itself and all
relationship to society so for Freud as
I just said you know the the human being
is not really cut out for happiness and
society's role is to you know keep the
human being under control I mean so we
don't go berserk and do you know go
around and slaughter people that's his
view and why society is important Reich
on the other hand thought that society
would really what repress the human
being and it was society's fault with
all its rules and regulations and norms
that people could not be as happy as
they had a potential to be and he
thought true happiness was about
becoming liberated as a human being who
was to become authentic
it was to become yourself and very very
crucial to that process to become
yourself it's also to at free yourself
sexually and for him it was to find your
org or gastic potency in other words be
able to have multiple orgasms or or at
least in a more sort of abstract way to
be free from various forms of sexual
inhibitions was that is that partnered
with being polyamorous as well was he
advocating multiple sexual partners yeah
I mean he was I mean I mean he would be
in favor of that
and he hated family he thought his
family was a disease he called this a
disease and called it family tease this
is a really strange guy his were really
worth to look into and he became more
and more obsessed with his theories of
this orgastic
energy and started to decide what is
called orgone accumulator which is this
wooden box like like one of these sort
of looking like one of these old
telephone booths and they were made out
of wood and coated with
some metals and you were supposed to
stand inside of these organ accumulators
and then receive the organ energy and
this then supposedly was going to to
heal you make your whole make you
authentic and make you sexual and all of
this may sound nuts
it sounds like Scientology well I mean
it sounds nuts like Scientology yes but
but the interesting thing is that we'll
hemorrhoid becomes extraordinarily
influential in places like Big Sur in
California in the 1940s with you know
the kind of early beat generation like
Sir Henry Miller is one of the first
people to really pick up I will have
RIKEN to find him as a guru and an
inspiration for the new kind of bohemian
lifestyle that was beginning to take
form and when the Esalen Institute
started in 1961 Wilhelm Reich was one of
the key people that they were influenced
by so much of what we see from that
point onwards and here in this time you
know I did 1950s 1960s is really the
first time were happiness becomes
something that everyone is supposed to
achieve and he's like it's like an
artifact of will homes will homes work
you think not not not only but I mean I
think I think the notion of happiness
that we subscribe to today is to a very
large extent shaped by some of those
ideas that wilhelm reich developed in in
his work and because if you think about
happiness which i do in this book as
being something that changes over time
but really what it does is that it
mirrors a set of values that happen to
be endorsed by that society in that
particular time then really what is
being favoured today on this
respect our previous conversation is a
to be authentic right you need to be
yourself you need to develop your own
individual sort of unique core of who
you are I mean that's really the
essential thing about being human today
the second thing is we need to live a
life which is filled with with pleasure
and I mean then ties of consumer
capitalism is I mean the moral and I
mean the moral and cultural foundation
for consumer capitalism is heaven isn't
it is that we should be able to enjoy
ourselves and then finally I think the
third value which is really key to
understand how yeah um to how we think
about happiness today is work and and
whether or not we are you know
successful through our work or if we're
able to achieve ourselves through this
work so is really there in at Esalen
Institute in the 1960s which will have
reich helped inspire that you had new
ideas such as the human potential
movement that what we should do in order
to become true to ourselves and fully
happy is to is defined and that untapped
potential within ourselves and to fully
develop our our inner potential and that
is really the kind of notion of
happiness that we subscribe to still
today but now in in the Arab who live in
that which is very different from how it
was in the nineteen sixties the
happiness fantasy consisting of these
values is used I'd leave more often than
not as a way as a way of of exploiting
people in or even you know as a
euphemism for for making us do things
which we know is bad for us
you know just work more or or and then
you know brainwash our self and say that
this is really what I want to do but I
think it
interesting that you touched on
capitalism earlier on that as soon as
you have a desire for anything
inevitably that opens up a market for it
and recently recently did a podcast with
Dan Harris's co-writer Jeff Oren and on
that podcast we discussed the fact that
meditation and mindfulness practice is
supposed to be this it's the dissolving
of the ego right it's it's complete
openness etc etc but as there's a move
towards mindfulness on a societal level
that also means that there's the option
for people to make money and as soon as
this is the option for people to make
money off it Charlotte and Cynthia and
people who want to exploit others who
want that in their life and think that
it's going to give them meaning so you
know people chasing happiness the demand
if the demand is there for something the
supply will not shoot it shortly
afterwards follow surely yeah I mean I
think I think just one sort of short
example or or illustration of how
ludicrous it has become today to think
about you know where you would find
instances of happiness or even authentic
happiness is a threat among share which
you know about obviously living in the
UK yes you know the the fast-food chain
where as part of their work culture the
employees are supposed not just to be
happy you know smile and greet the
customers and and take them on and give
them a sandwich they also need to do
that authentically and and that is when
you when you begin to see how these
values when they were first developed
you know in this case then with Wilhelm
Reich in the United 20s how they have
been transformed through market
capitalism through corporations which
you know very cunningly have been using
these words but then twisted them and
and made use of them for their own ends
that's really it's quite disturbing
isn't it that you've got you've got
someone who is saying that you need to
be authentically happy
and by the way the happiness that we're
talking about is narrowly defined within
the last hundred years or so
hmm so of all right of all of the
definitions of happiness that you've
come across have you got one which you
have found to be closest to what you
think happiness is of all of the years
that there's several thousand years or
without it it seems to be a fairly
despondent barren wasteland where this
happiness word is almost useless no I
mean not at all I mean I think I think
you could live a life with without
happiness I mean I think okay so my my
best sort of definition of happiness
there's not really a definition but
there's this sort of back and forth
between Vladimir and Estragon in Samuel
Beckett's play Waiting for Godot and I
think this is really a great
illustration or what happiness is so I
think it's Vladimir who goes first to
terrestre gone or the other way around
anyway he goes say that say that you're
happy why just say that you're happy
okay I am happy say it again I am happy
okay we are happy and then they say we
are happy and then Estragon goes what
should we do now now that we're happy
and I love that line because I mean I
think I think that you know if we become
happy the crises okay we'll do it at
dinner not happy and I think it points
to kind of the I mean it's it's such a
powerful concept because and it really I
think it's really a guiding principle
for how we live our lives and and in
that sense I mean I think I think it's
important because it really constitutes
the template for what what we consider
to be a good life as opposed to a bad
life which of course is contingent on on
the culture we live in but I believe you
could live without a clear definition of
happiness and instead use other words
such as meaning or you could use you
know where such as
or friendship I mean I think we we do
have enough concepts to guide us in our
pursuit to live meaningful good
fulfilling lives
in whatever way we like to do that but
but happiness is just such a broad and
vague abstract term that is now I think
use and have been for a long time by
politicians and corporations in in very
cunning and this ingenious ways so I
mean I'm quite tempted to think that
happiness is something we could leave to
the people working on the next
advertisement form are a soft drink or
some some fast food and then the rest of
us could could live happily ever form
that is it's interesting that you talk
about this kind of meta term of
happiness and it sounds to me an awful
lot like someone saying you need to be
good at sports and in no way does me
telling you that you need to be good at
sports help you become a good runner or
become a good cyclist because sports and
the achievement of being good at sports
is created by a much more granular set
of effect that build up towards that hmm
and I think yeah it's a very very
interesting view to have that that I
mean I'm sure everybody who is listening
and probably you yourself at some point
on social media will have seen the quote
happiness is the path not the
destination hmm and yeah - you know one
of this weird twists of fate that this
incredibly instagram-worthy sort of it
sounds like the sort of thing that you
could buy IKEA quote actually isn't
isn't a million miles away if what I'm
to take that you've said today is true
happiness is a set of guiding principles
in fact to a degree
happiness is almost the
optimiser it's the pinnacle of the
optimization ization strategy and you
aim you aim your trajectory towards that
and along the way you pick up the
appropriate prerequisites to meet
happiness and as long as you don't
expect it to ever arrive what actually
happens is you find fulfilment in the
small tasks that you accomplish along
the way yeah I mean I think that that
could that could be one way of doing it
definitely but I mean I think I think
the happiness or I mean another term
which which some people prefer to use
and I would agree with them is joy where
where joy is something that could arrive
in a more spontaneous way and I think
some people have argued and pascal
bruckner is one Lynd seagull is another
one that I agree with both of them that
what we need to be able to do is to be
open to and and not push happiness or
joy away but at its same time being
quite careful with how happiness and
immersing yourself you know doing
everything you can to achieve happiness
this is also in in many ways dangerous
because it could it could lead you
astray I mean because there's so many
people who will you know tell you what
what a happy life is I mean I think
another definition of this of course
this is from a sort of feminist movement
how how a happy woman has been very
closely bound up with how a woman should
be like you know it's the happy
housewife and her happiness is bound up
exclusively with making sure that her
family is happy that the man would have
her to his cleaner on the take IRA
dinner on the table and there's really
no happiness at all for that housewife I
mean if you if you go back and reread
the stats about how housewives felt in
the 1950s I mean they felt anything but
happiness but still they were really
that model of of happiness I mean
another example would be
gay people and does it sort for all this
name-dropping but it's just but sarah
hyland wrote this surah al-maida brought
his book the promise of happiness and
and and she makes a really good point I
think where how some parents would speak
to de gay people that well you know I
just want you to be happy which is a
euphemism for just please keep your
sexual identity to yourself limit of
normal and heterosexual life
so this decide to be happy and and
follow the roots of happiness could also
be extraordinarily constraining because
we have so specific ideas of what it
means to be happy and our sort of
happiness fantasies as I call it in this
book yeah tend to be very regulating and
you could be a happy in in in a number
of different ways but not too many
different different ways you need you
need to act it out according to and
accepted formula so in that sense and
this is interesting if you look at the
feminist movement because they were very
rarely speak about happiness but rather
about freedom yeah and and for them it
would even be if you take the housewife
example freedom from happiness because
happiness doesn't have more the kind of
happiness fantasies that they were being
trapped inside
yeah we're just miserable it just
produced misery and so I think you know
it might come a day where I will embrace
happiness fully again but but but for
now I think you know I'm still I'm still
waiting and and keenly so to see new
happiness fantasies to arrive or new
templates of what a meaningful life look
like which are you know less
individualistic than they are at the
moment we shall less focused on
competitiveness which are less focused
on on self mastery and instead more
focus I think on vulnerability on on
love on precariousness I mean how we
really are deeply dependent on each
other and the mores of communal and
collective ID of how we want to live
together I mean that to me is what
hopefully future happiness fantasy would
would look like what whose feet do you
think this falls at in terms of us
planting the flag on what proper
happiness are your potential remodeling
of happiness there could be is it a top
down is it governments is it education
is it the individuals responsibility to
realize this during the somewhat I mean
this movement needs to come from
somewhere in exactly the same way as it
was potentially led astray by some ideas
that have occurred within the last
couple of hundred years the same thing
needs to happen again to send it back in
the right direction have you got an idea
of where that trajectory could come from
well I mean I think I think that's the
is a very very sort of basic question of
sociology and and social and political
change and and even though there would
be no you know definite account of how
those changes emerge I mean they they're
always going to be an interplay of a
huge number of actors no and and I
wouldn't be able to speculate exactly
how such phenomena are gonna manifest
itself ya know but I mean I I just think
that the kind of happiness fantasy we
have now which I traced back to the
nineteen twenties in this figure of will
and right
and really comes to fruition in the
1960s and 1970s have now developed into
a job Trump who is also someone who
really endorsed these values of our
present day happiness fantasy that it's
really come to a point where we need
other templates for happy happy lives
and of course there are other templates
out there but I think the one that had
been so dominant in the lost parts of
the 20th century
and up today would really need to be
child
in a more radical way than 10 it has and
and we'll we'll see where where that may
come from or if it won't come from from
anywhere or may not yeah so colored I've
absolutely loved this I I like how we
can see the trajectory from the Wellness
syndrome then moving into what you did
with the optimization and then it does
seem like there's an awful lot consider
few said in advance that these three
books have all got an awful lot in
common I would have probably struggled
to work out where it would go but it
does sound like there's a certainly a
story arc to what you're looking at or
what you've been researching over the
last few years
very nicely tied together well thank you
I mean I think I think that's this has
been been an occupation and happiness
and and unwholesome self-help culture
and how central that they are to our
present day culture and finding ways to
just understand it a little bit better
mm-hmm I understand completely
would you be able to tell the listeners
at home where they can find you online
well yeah I mean I I'm kind of one on
Twitter that's it really I mean apart
from that I'm not a bird I'm not very
present on online you're a ghost
IRA ghost in the dark that's what you
are yeah I'm out there I guess I'll make
sure I'll make sure that the link to
your Twitter is your nose um when is the
happiness fantasy being released because
I've got a manuscript version on my
Kindle moment I'm gonna guess it's not
that one that's going out I think I
think I mean I just got an advance copy
a few days ago so I think it's coming
out in in a couple of weeks probably
fantastic well I will make sure that the
will there be a pre-order link up on
Amazon yeah there should be something
like that
fantastic I'll make sure you can kill it
you can kill the publishers if not I
will make sure that the link to
desperately seeking self-improvement the
wellness syndrome and the happiness
fantasy
or potentially the email address of your
publishers so everyone can send them a
nasty email is going well thank you
thank you so much yeah it's been
absolute blast Karl I've really enjoyed
all of the insights and good luck with
whatever you move on to next time I'm
sure yeah I'll be very interesting thank
you Chris really enjoy time Cheers okay
Cheers
[Music]